Oh for muse of fire that would ascend
the brightest heaven of invention a
kingdom for stage Prince's to act and
monarchs to behold the swelling scene
then should the warlike having like
himself assume the port of Mars and at
his heels leashed in like hounds should
famine sword and fire crouch for
employment the pan and gentle saw the
flat unrated spirits that have dared on
this unworthy scaffold to bring forth so
great an object can this cockpit hold
the vasty fields of France or maybe
crammed with in this was an odor free
casks that did a fide the air at a
jingle upon since a crooked figure may
attest in his place a million and let us
Cypress to this great accompt on your
mansion airy forces were suppose within
the girdle of these warm was unwelcome
find two mighty monarchies whose high up
with and abutting fronts the perilous
narrow ocean parts asunder peace out our
imperfections real thoughts into a
thousand parts divide one man and make
imaginary persons think when we talk of
horses that you see them printing their
proud hoofs in the receiving earth what
is your thoughts that's now must deck
our kings carry them here and there
jumping over x turning the
accomplishment of many years into an
hourglass for which supply admit me
chorus to this history who prologue like
your humble patients play gin need to
hear kindly to judge how play